thank you good evening New York hello
it's great to be with you
there's such an amazing energy out here
Bravo I want to thank you all from the
bottom of my heart and all the artists
who use to their voices to call for
change
Global citizen I hear you loud and clear
and Europe is answering your call
[Music]
we must put an end to hunger
and I am happy to announce that Europe
is mobilizing
600 million euros for food Security in
Africa the Caribbean and Civic
and we need to defeat deadly diseases
like malaria AIDS and tuberculosis
and that's why we are providing
715 million euros to the global fund
and today my friends I am pledging an
additional 45 million euros to the U.N
population funds so important
[Music]
we have to take care of our girls and
our women they deserve it
and my friends
we must also take care of our planet
so Europe will provide 7 billion euros
to protect biodiversity around the globe
nature needs our help and I call on the
world leaders to step up and I count on
you to drive us forward thank you have a
great evening thanks a lot
joining our